quand on est con on est con
ouais ça c'est bien c'est la dernière
ligne droite pour naïma avec son texte
sur les cons elle va participer au
concours d'éloquence depuis le 1er mars
cet habitant de conflans sainte honorine
participent à des ateliers d'art
oratoire je me suis aperçu dès la
première séance que en fait
se bat non en fait on sait pas parler et
non c'est même pas écouter les autres
petit à petit en fait non je me suis
prise au jeu et maintenant je me dis non
seulement tu vas y aller tu vas gagner
aussi tant qu'à faire
en fait bien les choses et lui donc j'ai
pris confiance en moi en fait ce jour là
isabelle men l'atelier cette professeur
de théâtre donne les dernières
techniques d'art oratoire il est plus
facile pour quelqu'un d'intelligent
d'être parfois qu'on
que pour un con
d'être intelligent
depuis le 1er mars 2022 ils sont douze
personnes à suivre ces ateliers tous les
mardis une initiative mise en place par
le conseil départemental des yvelines
l'idée pour nous était que des personnes
puissent quel que soit l'environnement
que ce soit dans le cercle familial dans
le cercle social bien sûr
professionnelle elle beaucoup plus à
l'aise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
originaire des comores à midi juriste de
formation elle vit à mantes la jolie a
décidé de participer à cet atelier pour
être plus à l'aise lors de ses
entretiens d'embauché quand je suis venu
ça m'a intéressé parce que je trouve que
j'évolue un petit appétit partie de ce
qu'on fait tous les jours tous les
mardis il ya une grande évolution parce
qu'on va voir quand j'ai parlé j'ai
tremblé tout maintenant je vois qu'on ça
va cesser 10 min
après trois mois de travail tous les
participants sont prêts pour le concours
prévu le 10 juin à la médiathèque blaise
cendras de conflans sainte honorine
[Musique]